حياكم الله قدما مشرعون امريكيون مشروع
قانون لحظر تطبيق التواصل الاجتماعي موقع
التواصل الاجتماعي الصيني تيك توك واعلن
سيناتور الجمهوريه ماركو روبيو عن تشريع
مدعوم من اعضاء من الحزبين الجمهوري
والديمقراطي لحظر تطبيق وسط مخاوف امريكي
من امكانيه استخدام التطبيق في التجسس على
الامريكيين وقال مكتب السنه والجمهوري في
بيان صحفي ان التشريع سيحضر جميع
المعاملات من جانب اي شركه تواصل اجتماعي
في الصين وروسيا او تخضع لنفودهما متحدثين
باسمي تيك توك ذكر انه من المدير للقلق
انه بدلا من تشجيع الاداره على استكمال
مراجعتها الصله بالامن القومي للتيك توك
قرر بعض اعضاء الكونغرس الضغط من اجل
مدفوع سياسيه لان يعود بالنفع على تعزيز
الامن القومي للولايات المتحده مضيفا ان
الشركه ستواصل
اعضاء الكونجرس على الخطط التي تمضي بشكل
جيد من اجل تعزيز التامين المنصه في
الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
معنا من القاهره الدكتور محمد الشهاوي
الخبير الامني والاستراتيجيه ومن سان
فرانسيسكوبي ولايه كاليفورنيا الدكتور
احمد منافع الخبير في تكنولوجيا المعلومات
ليبدا منك دكتور احمد اهلا بكم اولا ليبدا
معك يا دكتور احمد يعني لماذا لا تخشى
الولايات المتحده من هذا الموقع الاجتماعي
تيك توك هل هي خائفه بالفعل على على امنها
القومي
منصه التواصل الاجتماعي ام ان الامر بعيد
خاصه ان تيك توك قدمت كل ما لديها وحتى
انها نقلت مراكز البيانات الى الولايات
المتحده
السؤال جيد جدا
التطبيق خطير لان المعلومات اللي يتم
جمعها من التطبيق معلومات كبيره بما فيها
موقع الشخص بما فيها ال ال مقاطع الفيديو
حتى مقاطع الفيديو اللي لسه ما حملها
موجوده اضافه الى انه ممكن تاثر على الراي
العام احنا نتكلم على حوالي 100 مليون شخص
يستخدم تك توك في في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هنا
اكثر 138 طيب يعني وين الخوف الامريكي هل
فقط
الاشخاص ام هو اا هذه البيانات تترجم الى
اشياء اخرى وقد تستخدم من قبل هذا الموقع
هذه المعلومات بيستخدموها في في عده اشياء
تاثير على الراي العام الحصول على اينو
على مزاج الاشخاص اللي في اللي في امريكا
الانتخابات القادمه فانت كون انك تعرف
بالضبط اتجاه المجتمع الامريكي بيقدروا
ياثروا فيه فهذه هي المشكله اللي واقعين
فيها الان في امريكا يعني هذا هذا القرار
اللي اعضاء الكونغرس تقدموا في هو سياسي
ام امني بالمقام الاول كما تقول التيك توك
من انه سياسي وليس امنيه فيها
الواقع انه سياسي وامني في نفس الوقت لانه
مثل ما فضلت في تقريركم الرئيس السابق
ترامب حاول يمنعه ويعني وصل الى مرحله
بانه حول الخوادم بحيث انها تكون موجوده
هنا في امريكا لكن عمليه دخول المعلومات
لسه موجوده للسلطات الصينيه الى الان طيب
دكتور محمد الشهاوي الخبير الامني
والاستراتيجي من القاهره حينما نتحدث عن
الولايات المتحده كل هذا العملاق الضخم في
التكنولوجيا لماذا هذه الخشيه ليست مبالغا
فيها من انك لا تستطيع ان تتحكم خاصه ان
هذا التطبيق اعطاء قاعده البيانات في
الولايات المتحده وليست في الصين او حتى
روسيا
اهلا بك يا فندم مضيفك الكريم ومشاهدين
القناه الكرام انا بقول فعلا ان خوف
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هو فعلا بيمس
لاء من القول وكلمه الامن القومي دي احنا
بنعرفها ان الامن القومي له مجالات ليس
المجال العسكري فقط ولكن الامن الاجتماعي
والامن الاقتصادي ازاي ازاي ان احنا ناثر
على معنويات الافراد ازاي ان احنا ناثر
على المزاج العام ازاي ان احنا نوجه الراي
العام في اتجاه محدد بالاضافه ناهيك عن
استخدام الجاسوسيه ايضا لها دور كبير في
هذا الاطار المواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لها
يعني سلبيات بالاضافه الى ايضا ايجابيات
لكن من سلبياتها ان هناك ست اسباب تؤثر
على القوى العاقيه للافراد بالاضافه الى
اختراق الخصوصيه احنا نعلم ان مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي بالمجان لماذا لان
الثمن هو معلومات هذا الشخص هذا الفرض
الذي يستخدم مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي هو
احيانا هناك ما يسمى بمدمنه مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي واحنا في العلوم الاجتماعيه
بيطلق عليها مدمني السرايا الزرقاء وليس
السرايا الصفراء لان هناك بعض الافراد
وخاصه من الشباب بيجلسوا ساعات طوال امام
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بيضيع وقت بيقلل
بيقلل وقت التحصيل والدراسه يؤدي الى
التشويش والتشتيت بالاضافه ايضا الى ان
العلاقات الاسريه ايضا بتهدم من خلال
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وعاوز اا يعني
اذكر سيادتك ان في مصر هنا يعني في نائب
اليوم طلب بحضر تطبيق التيك توك في مصر
نتيجه لان هناك يعني تحدي جديد على التيك
توك يسمى كتم الانفاس في المدارس
الاعداديه والمدارس الابتدائيه هذا خطا
مستخدم وليس خطا يعني ليس خطا تطبيق خطا
مستقدم
بينتشر انا باتكلم عن مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي باقول عليها مواقع التدمير
السريع الشامل لان مثل تلك التطبيقات
بتنتشر يعني مليار شخص حول العالم
بيستخدمه تطبيق التيك توك بالاضافه ايضا
ان احنا عندنا حكم على يعني في قضيه مهمه
جدا تسمى قضيه فتيات توك توك وهي يعني
حنين حسام وموده الادهم وحكم عليهم فعلا
لان ذلك ضد العادات وضد التقاليد يتم
استخدامها على مواقع التواصل غير محمد
وخاصه التيك توك يعني
ينطبق على سناب شات او انستغرام وغيرها
فيسبوك مثلا ما هي ايضا تاخذ همم
معلومات عن الشخص ومزاج السؤال ده مهم جدا
فعلا هو مثل ذلك ولكنها انتشارا لي يعني
الفيديوهات فيديوهات التيك توك بتكون اكثر
اكثر ترافه بالاضافه الى السرعه في
الانتشار بين همم بين المواطنين وخاصه
الشباب منهم وعلشان كده فعلا الامن القومي
ليس هو فقط المجاري العسكري ولكن الامن
الاجتماعي والامن الاقتصادي بس انا عايز
اقول في هذه النقطه ان يعني طلع بيان من
همم يعني همم مجموعه الوايت همم البايت
دانس بتقول ان اغلى ان المدير التنفيذي
اللي موجود في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
هو امريكي هو كل البيانات بتوجد في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وان ذلك هو
يعني مناكفه سياسيه بتقوم بها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه كان في 2020 في اغسطس
الرئيس الامريكي دونالد ترامب يعني طالب
بحظر تطبيق توك توك ولكن في من العام
الماضي الرئيس جو بايدن هو من قام بالسماح
بتعليق همم هذا بحظر التعليق يعني علق هذا
الحظر والان ثلاث نواب من الكونجرس
بيقوموا يعني مشروع قانون لحضاره
يعني يذهب الى الدكتور احمد منافع دكتور
شهاوي ساذهب الى الدكتور احمد نافع هل
الولايات المتحده اليوم تخشى من هذا الخطر
فقط ام اي انها تخشى خساره النفود من خلال
هذا
المجال الفضائي وبالتالي هي تسعى الى
الخوارزميات التي لا يمكن الصين ان تعطيها
الى الولايات المتحده عبر هذا التطبيق
ادي نقطه مهمه جدا يا اخي الكريم الا هي
الولايات المتحده خسرت الان بسبب ان تك
تاك هو رقم واحد بالذات للجيل الجديد وكون
انه اسلوبه في التعامل مع مقاطع الفيديو
الشباب اللي يحملوها بطريقه يعني
بالفلترات وباشياء كثيره هذه الجذبه كثير
يعني مئات الملايين يعني واحد فاصله اثنين
مليار مستخدم دخل 4.6 مليار في عام 20 21
18% من المستخدمين الانترنت بيستخدم فهما
خسروا في الحاله هذه
فكثير من الامور اللي نظره لها انه هذه
فرصه عندهم على انه هم يبطئوا تقدم الصين
في هذه اضافه نقطه اخرى يا اخي الكريم
تفضل لو لاحظت انه لما صدر هذه البيان من
همم من روبيو من الاثنين وقابل اللي في
الكونغرس الاسهم تبعت سناب شات وتتابعت
فيسبوك ارتفعت بسبب انه عارفين انه بيزيح
منافس لهم من السوق خدي واحده اضافه على
انه تك تاك مش ساكت احنا عندنا في
السيليكون همم فاليو وادي السيليكون هناك
قبل حوالي شهر تك توك اشترت
مبنيين كبار كل مبنى فيهم سبع يعني ادوار
كل مبنى منهم يعني ممكن يتحمل 1500 مره في
يعني معدل ثلاثه الاف موظف بيشغلوهم داخل
هنا في وادي السيليكون على اساس انه
بيوضحوا الحكومه الامريكيه ان احنا الشركه
الامريكيه المشكله اللي هم واقعين فيها
المشكله الواقعين فيها انه ثبتت من خلال
تقارير البيئه والجهات الاخرى على انه الى
الان في قابليه على انه طيب اشخاص من
الصين يدخلوا على هذا الخوادم
بالضبط
في التكنولوجيا المعلومات من سان
فرانسيسكو ولا الدكتور همم محمد الشهاوي
الخبير الامني والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من
القاهره الشكر موصول لك ايضا
شكرا لكم انتم
لمتابعيه بانوراما المزيد من الاخبار مع
زملاء في نشراتنا المستمر في امان الكريم